maybe we could talk about like i had a
conversation
about this with my dad a little bit um
how does uh religion relate to this
i see it as the uh the disease and the
cure
um in in a sense um
a few things um
one is that
i think a case could be made that humans
are
innately religious
uh so now we're going to get into
territory where there's going to be
a lot of disputes um and
by what do you mean by religious the
religion is an evolutionary
adaptation and religion is like a belief
in something outside of yourself kind of
thing
not necessarily so here we got to be a
little bit more
careful and
again i'm not a scholar how about i'm a
well-intentioned dilettante in this in
this regard
yeah because what what i have read
is that religion um
evolved very early on
long before our ancestors were conscious
and the issue of death arose um
and uh um the word religion
evidently is from a latin word regatta
we can look it up but and it means to
bind
and emil durkheim the dead french
sociologist he said
you know originally religion is a darce
lassen who's a
dead novelist she calls it the substance
of
we feeling that it's literally
that it arose because we're uber
social creatures who from time to time
took comfort in just being in physical
proximity
with our uh fellow humans
and that there is this kind of
sense of transcendent
exuberance just back to the
unshakable joy that heidegger alludes to
and that the original
function of religion was to foster
social cohesion
and coordination and that it was only
subsequently some claim
that a burgeoning level of consciousness
made it such
that religious belief systems
that included the hope of some kind of
immortality
were just naturally selected thereafter
so there are some people so
it's david sloane wilson
wrote a book called darwin's cathedral
and he said religion has nothing to do
with death it's a it evolved
to make groups viable he's actually a
group
selection guy what's group selection um
the idea that um it's the group that is
selected for
rather than the individual individuals
yeah so people have vigorous
disagreements about that
but i guess our point would be we see
religion
as being inextricable inextricably
connected
ultimately to assuaging concerns
about death well i guess another
question to ask around this uh like what
what does the world look like without
religion
will we if it's uh inextricably
inextricably connected uh to our fears
of death
do you think it always returns in some
kind of shape
maybe it's not called religion but
whatever it just keeps returning
yeah who knows so that's a that's a
great question alex so there's a woman
named
karen armstrong she was a non-turned
historian and
she's i can't remember the name of the
book
but no matter she we could look that up
but
if you want i can look it up but i can
also i'll just yeah
okay yeah her point it says that's god
in the title of course but
you know she's like look all religions
are generally fairly right-minded in
that they
advocate the golden rule and
all religions at their best
do seem to foster pro-social behavior
towards the in-group and that confers
both psychological as well as physical
benefits
that's the good news and the bad news is
historically all religions are
subject to being hijacked by a lunatic
french who declares
that you know they're the ones in sole
possession
of the liturgical practices or whatever
they call them
and they're the ones that turn
you know religion at its best into your
crusades and holocausts
my view not that it should matter for
much
but i i'm
i grew up just skeptical of religion
because i'm like as a kid
i'm like well if we didn't have these
beliefs we wouldn't be killing each
other
right because of them and i'd be like to
my parents well you're telling me that
all people
should be judged on the merits of their
character
but don't come home if you don't marry a
jewish woman
right which is implying that if you're
not jewish you're an inferior form of
life
yeah that's what tribes always do yeah
and there's the tribal thing
and so there's a guy named amin malouf a
lebanese
guy who writes in french in the 1990s i
think
wrote a book called in the name of
identity
violence and the need to belong and
that was his point is
unless we can overcome this tribal
mentality this will not end well
but but you said earlier something lex
that i think is profound and profoundly
important
and that is you did not recoil in horror
when i mentioned kierkegaard's use of
the term
faith and so i'm a big fan of faith
and i'm not sure what that implies
i i have and by the way this is just a
peripheral comment but i find less
resistance to becker's ideas and our
work
when i'm in like jesuit schools
you know it's the americans that you
know the secular humanists
who are most disinclined
to accept these ideas it's an important
side comment because uh
i think it's mostly because they don't
think philosophically that's
i mean i speak with a lot of scientists
and um i think that's my main
uh criticism is is you don't
i mean that's the problem with science
exactly is it's so comforting
to focus in on the details that you can
escape
thinking about the mystery of it all the
big picture things the philosophical
like
the fact that you don't actually know
[ __ ] at all like that
that uh that that yeah so the the
in terms of jesuit like that's yeah
that's the beauty of
uh the experience of faith and so on is
like
uh how wherever that journey takes you
is you
you actually explore the biggest
questions of our world yeah
yeah so i don't see religion going away
because
i don't see humans
as capable of surviving without faith
and hope and
everyone from the pope to elon musk
will acknowledge that it is a world that
is unfathomably mysterious
and like it or not in the absence of
beliefs here i'm
charles purse the pragmatic philosopher
he just said beliefs are the basis of
action if you don't have any beliefs
you're paralyzed with indecision
whether we're aware of it or not whether
we like it or not
in order to stand up in the morning you
have to subscribe to beliefs
that can never be unequivocally
proven right or wrong well then why do
you
maintain them well ultimately it's
because of some form of faith
but also also faith shouldn't be a
dogmatic thing that uh
you should always be leaping yeah i
guess uh the problem with science or
with religion is uh
uh you could sort of uh all of a sudden
take a step into a place where you're
super confident
that you know the absolute truth of
things there you go
and again back to socrates plato back in
the cave
uh you know at skidmore where i work
that's what i have the students read in
their first week
you know and plato's like oh look at all
those poor bastards you know they're in
the cave but they don't know
it you know and then they are
freed from their chains and they have to
be dragged out of the cave by the way
which is another interesting
point they don't run out but that gets
back to why
people don't like to be divested of
their comfortable illusions but anyway
they get dragged out of the cave into
the sunlight which he claims
is a representation of truth and beauty
and i say to the students well what's
wrong with that
and they're like nothing that's like
awesome
and then i'm like yo dudes
you out of the cave but how do you know
that you're not in
another cave the illumination may be
better
right but the minute you think
you're at the end of the proverbial
intellectual slash epistemological trail
then you have already succumbed
to either laziness or dogmatism or both
that's really well put
that's both terrifying and exciting that
that we're always it's
there's always a bigger cave
you